[Music]
initially I just wanted to be an
underwater Explorer
[Music]
but shortly after becoming a diver I
realized that the perfect way for me to
explore the ocean was with a camera
[Music]
my name is Brian scary and I'm a
National Geographic magazine
photographer that specializes in ocean
wildlife
Buck Island is this spectacular coral
reef
you feel like you're in a storybook
[Music]
you drift through this place and you see
these stands of alcohol
reaching up like the uplifted arms of a
statue toward the sky
[Music]
and they have that beautiful oranjee
golden color
[Music]
I'm here on Buck Island as one of the
components of my story for National
Geographic magazine
right now you know there are very few
places in US waters that are fully
protected but yet on land the national
parks have been called America's best
idea
[Music]
single photograph can move that agenda
forward it can really wake people up
[Music]
there's a lot of stresses on sea turtle
populations
because this place is protected those
numbers have recovery
you're on the beach watching the
hatchlings emerge your heart goes out to
these little guys there they're
struggling as they break through their
shell and dig out through the sand
[Music]
and these little beautiful nuggets of
turtle have to now scramble to the ocean
[Music]
I feel privileged to be able to say it
[Music]
buck island was one of the very first
marine national monuments that was
created by President Kennedy in 1961
[Music]
from the air you see that glowing
crystal-clear water
[Music]
blues and the aquas and the greens it is
a jewel
I think my role as a photographer is to
tell a story I want to use the
centennial anniversary of the National
Park Service in the United States of
America
to bring attention to places that are
protected and places not yet protected
but ones that we hope someday will be
these places are vulnerable and they're
fragile and a single bottom trawl net
could tow through one of these places
and destroy it for generations and it
would be gone with a whimper nobody
would ever know that it existed
[Music]
but I think there's also reasons to be
hopeful I think we're at a moment in
history where we at least know what can
happen if you protect places that they
do come back that the ocean is resilient
with the right amount of protection and
management love these places will
restore themselves
[Music]